I'm the product of a bold leadership
decision after 1956 when Tunisia became
independent our first president Habib
Bourguiba decided to invest 20 percent
of the country's national budget in
education yes 20 percent on the high end
of the spectrum even by today's
standards some people protested what
about infrastructure what about
electricity roads and running water
are these not important I would argue
that the most important infrastructure
we have our minds educated minds
president Bourguiba helped establish
free high-quality education for every
boy and every girl and together with
millions of other Tunisians I'm deeply
indebted to that historic decision and
that's what brought me here today
because today we are facing a global
learning crisis I call it learning
crisis and not education crisis because
on top of the quarter of a billion
children who are out of school today
even more 330 million children are in
school but failing to learn and if we do
nothing if nothing changes by 2030 just
13 years from now half of the world's
children and youth half of 1.6 billion
children and youth will be either out of
school or failing to learn so two years
ago I joined the Education Commission
it's a commission brought together by
former UK Prime Minister and UN Special
Envoy for global education Gordon Brown
our first task was to find out how big
is the learning crisis what's actually
the scope of the problem today we know
half of the word children bite
30 will be failing to learn and that's
how actually we discovered that we need
to change the words focus from schooling
to learning from just counting how many
bodies are in classroom to actually how
many are learning and the second biggest
asked was can we do anything about this
can we do anything about this big vast
silent may be most neglected
international crisis and what we found
out is we can it's actually amazing we
can for the first time have every child
in school and learning within just one
generation and we don't even have to
really invent the wheel to do so we just
need to learn from the best in class but
not any best in class the best in your
own class what we did is actually we
looked at countries by income level low
income mid income high income we looked
at what the 25 percent fastest improvers
and education do and what we found out
is that if every country moves at the
same rate as the fastest improvers
within their own income level then
within just one generation we can have
every child in school and learning let
me give you an example let's take
Tunisia for example we're not telling
Tunisia you should move as fast as
Finland
no disrespect Roland we're telling
Tunisia look at Vietnam they spent
similar amounts for primary and
secondary pupils as percentage of GDP
per capita but achieves today higher
results Vietnam introduced under that
assessment for literacy and numeracy
teachers in Vietnam are better monitored
as in other developing countries and
students achievements are made public
and it shows in the results in the 2015
Pisa program for International Student
Assessment Vietnam outperformed many
wealthy economies including the United
States
now if you're not an education expert
you may ask what's new and different
don't all countries track student
progress and make those achievements
public now the sad answer is no we have
very far from it
only half of the developing countries
have systemic learning assessment at
primary school and even less so at lower
secondary school so if we don't know if
children are learning how our teachers
supposed to focus their attention on
delivering results and how our country
is supposed to prioritize the education
spending actually on what deliver
results if they don't know if children
are learning that's why the first big
transformation before investing is to
make education system deliver results
because pouring more money and broken
systems may only fund more
inefficiencies and what deeply worries
me if children go to school and don't
learn it devalues education and it
devalues spending in education so that
governments and political party can say
who we're spending so much money in
education but children are not learning
they don't have the right skills maybe
we should spend less now improving
current education system to deliver
results is important but won't be enough
what about countries where we won't have
enough qualified teachers take Somalia
for example if every student in Somalia
became teacher every person who finishes
tertiary education became teacher we
won't have enough teachers and what
about children in refugee camps or in
very remote rural areas take Philippa
for example Philippa lives in one of the
thousands communities alongside the
Amazonas reverse his village of 78
people has 20 families Philippi and a
fellow student
we're the only two attending grade 11 in
2015 now the Amazonas is a state in the
northwest of Brazil it's
one a half times the size of Germany and
it's fully covered in jungle and rivers
a decade ago Philippi and his fellow
student would have had just two
alternatives moving to Manaus the
capital or stopping studying altogether
which most of them did in 2009 however
Brazil passed a new law that made
secondary education a guarantee for
every Brazilian and an obligation for
every state to implement this by 2016
but giving access to high-quality
education you know in the amazonas state
is huge and expensive how are you gonna
get you know math and science and
history teachers all over those
communities and even if you find them
many of them would not want to move
there
so faced with this impossible task civil
servants and state officials developed
amazing creativity and entrepreneurship
they developed the media center solution
it works this way you have specialized
trained content teachers in Manaus
delivering classroom via livestream to
over thousand classrooms in those
scattered communities those classrooms
have 5 to 25 students and they're
supporting by a more generalist to
tutoring teacher for the Learning and
Development the 60 content teachers in
Manaus work with to over 2,200 tutoring
teachers in those communities to
customize lessons plans to the context
and time now why is this division
between content teacher and tutoring
teacher important first of all as I told
you because in many countries we just
don't have enough qualified teachers but
secondly also because teachers do too
many things they're either not trained
for or not supposed to do let's look at
Chile for example in Chile for every
doctor you have four and a half people
four and a half staff supporting them
and Chile is on now and let's say Chile
is on the low end of the spectrum here
because in developing countries on
average every doctor has ten people
supporting them
a teacher in Chile however has less than
half a person 0.3 person supporting them
imagine a hospital ward was 20 40 70
patients and you have a doctor doing it
all by themselves no nurses no medical
assistants no one else you will say this
is absurd and impossible but this is
what teachers are doing all over the
world every day with classroom of 20 40
or 70 students so this division between
content and tutoring teachers is amazing
because it's changing the paradigm of
the teacher so that each does what they
can do best and so that children are not
just in school but in school and
learning and some of this content
teacher they became celebrity teacher
you know some of them run for office and
they had raised the status of the
profession so that more students wanted
to become teachers and what I love about
this example is beyond the changing the
paradigm of the teacher it teaches us
how can we harness technology for
learning the life streaming is
bi-directional so students like Philippi
and other can present information back
and we know technology is not always
perfect you know state officials expect
between 5 to 15% of the classrooms every
day to be off live stream because of
flood broken antennas or internet not
working and yet Philippi is one of over
300,000 students that benefited from the
Media Center solution and got so access
to post primary education this is a
living example how technology is not
just an add-on but can be central to
learning and can help us bring school to
children if we cannot bring children to
school now I hear you you're gonna say
how are you going to implement this all
over the world I've been in government
myself and have seen how difficult it is
even to implement the best ideas so as a
commission we started two initiatives to
make the learning generation and reality
the first one called the Pioneer country
initiative over 20 countries from Africa
and Asia have committed to make
education their priority and to
transform the education systems to
deliver results we've trained country
leaders in a methodology called the
delivery approach what this does is
basically two things in the planning
phase we take everyone into one room
teachers teacher Union parents are
Association government officials NGOs
everyone so that the reform in the
solution we come up with are shared by
everyone and supported by everyone and
in the second phase it does something
special it's kind of a ruthless focus on
follow-up so in a way that week by week
you check has that been done what was
supposed to be done and even sometimes
sending a person physically to the
district or school to check that versus
just hoping for it that it happened
it may sound for many common sense but
it's not common practice and that's why
actually many reforms fail it has been
piloted in Tanzania and there the past
rate for students and secondary
education was increased by 50% in just
over two years now the next initiative
to make the learning generation your
reality is financing who's going to pay
for this so we believe an argue that
domestic financing has to be the
backbone of education investment you
remember when I told you about Vietnam
earlier outperforming the United States
in Pisa that's due to a better education
system but also to Vietnam increasing
their investment from 7 to 20 percent of
the national budget in two decades but
what happens if countries want to borrow
money for education if you wanted to
borrow money to build a bridge or Road
it's quite easy and straightforward but
not for education it's easier to make a
shiny picture of a bridge and show it to
everyone then then one of educated mind
that's kind of a longer term commitment
so we came up with this solution to help
countries escape the
middle-income track countries that are
not poor enough or not poor thankfully
anymore that cannot profit from grants
or interest-free loans and they're not
rich enough to be able to have
attractive interest on their loans
so we're pooling donor money in a
finance facility for education which
will provide more finance for education
we will subsidize or even eliminate
completely interest payments on the
loans so that countries to commit to
reforms can borrow money reform the
education system and pay this money over
time while benefiting from a better
educated population this solution has
been recognized in the last g20 meeting
in Germany and so finally today
education is on the international agenda
but let me bring this back to the
personal level because this is where the
impact lands without that decision to
invest a young country's budget twenty
percent of a young country budget in
education I would have never been able
to go to school let alone in 2014
become a minister in a government that
successfully ended the transition phase
to newzeas Nobel Peace Prize in 2015 as
the only democracy that emerged from the
Arab Spring is a legacy to that bold
leadership decision education is the
civil rights struggle it's the human
rights struggle of our generation
quality education for all that's the
freedom fight that we've gotta win thank
you
you